[Music]
[Music]
hello my name is frank kane and i'm the
owner of sundog education you're joining
over half a million people around the
world who have learned machine learning
and big data and data science with me
and today we're going to talk about xg
boost in depth a little bit more in
depth actually than we talked about in
my course even so i hope this is helpful
for you guys we're going to do things a
little bit backwards here so normally i
talk about the theory first for a while
and do some slides and then i show you
an example but i'm going to jump right
into the example right now this time and
get your feet wet and just show you what
it can do then we'll come back and
discuss the theory in a little bit more
detail and go through the code again to
understand it a little bit better so
let's just hop right over to my other
monitor here
and i have a very simple jupiter
notebook here so we're going to be
talking about using xgboost within a
python environment specifically this is
within anaconda so if you are new to
this whole field kind of step one is to
go install anaconda on your system which
will give you the scientific python
environment that you need to do machine
learning and run things like xgboost on
your own system
now xgboost doesn't usually come
pre-installed with these things so the
first thing you need to do is actually
install it which is super easy you just
go to your terminal or your command
prompt or your anaconda prompt whatever
your operating system has and just type
in pip install xgboost and you're done
that's all there is to it
xgboost is really cool it's one of the
most powerful machine learning
algorithms out there and as you will see
it's very easy to use i'm going to talk
about the dataset a little bit more
later but again i just want to dive in
and get you results as soon as possible
here so we're going to be using the iris
data set within this specific example
and that's a very common sort of test
data set that people use in these sorts
of examples
what it is is a data set of various
measurements of iris flowers and it
turns out that there are two different
kinds of petals in an iris one is called
the petal which is sort of the outer
petals of it and there's the sepal which
is sort of this underneath the petal
that supports the the outer petals and
by taking these measurements of the left
length and width of each petal and sepal
our challenge is to predict what species
of iris we're talking about here so
that's what this dataset's all about
first thing we do is load it up and we
just it's that's built into scikit-learn
which is a popular
library for doing machine learning
within python so we just say from
scikit-learn data sets import load iris
all we do is load up that data set we
can pre-load the number of samples and
the number of features within that data
set here features is just you know what
are the attributes that we're trying to
use to predict that uh species on in
this case it's four
that would be the pedal length and width
and the supple length and width width
and we just print that out to make sure
that it makes sense sure enough we have
150 different samples in this data set
it's pretty small and four features like
we said the width and length of the
pedal and supple and the target names
are what we're trying to predict so it
can be one of three species of iris
setosa versus color or virginica now
obviously in the real world you're going
to be spending a lot more time preparing
your data cleaning your data doing
feature engineering we're not going to
get into that in this lecture here
because that's a much bigger topic we do
go into more depth on our my larger
course on that on machine learning and
data science but anyway we're going to
start off by importing this in uh
splitting it up into a train test split
that's what's going on here so basically
we're going to take um in this case 20
of our data and reserve it for testing
and we're going to take the remaining 80
and use that to actually train our xg
boost model and that way we can make
sure that we can evaluate the
performance of this model on data that's
never seen before we're going to talk
about that in a lot more depth shortly
finally we get into the guts of xg boost
and we say we're going to import xg
boost itself as xgb and we need to set
up what's called a d matrix structure
within it
d matrix is basically a data structure
associated with xgboost xgboost is not
just made for scikit-learn it's not just
made for python it has its own api
basically and its api expects something
called a d matrix for its training data
and its testing data so that's what
we're creating here fortunately it's
very easy to do here we just say xgb.d
matrix pass in the training data and the
testing data with the appropriate labels
that we want to use to train that with
as well again if you're new to machine
learning we're going to dive into this
in more depth shortly let's go ahead and
run these before we forget
so let's go ahead and load up this first
block i'm just hitting shift enter to
execute that and that will load up our
data set
and now i'm gonna click on this
that's gonna perform the splitting up of
that data into training and test data
and we will run this to actually convert
that to the format that xg boost expects
all right next we need to set up some
parameters and we're going to talk about
hyper parameter tuning later on these
are basically all the knobs and dials
that you use to adjust how xg boost
works how deep do you want the trees to
get how fast do you want the learning
rate to be
what objective function do you want to
use to actually measure how good it's
doing how many classes do we have that
we're predicting here in this case it's
three those three different species of
iris that we're trying to protect and
how many epochs do you run how many
iterations do you want to actually go
through to try to converge on the best
model so let's go ahead and set those up
and now we can just do the training with
one line of code and uh that's kind of
the the dirty little secret of machine
learning well one of many actually it's
really really easy to do these days uh
in pretty much any model you can just
say
you take your model and say train pass
it in your training data and any hyper
parameters that you want and it just
does it so that's all that's going on
here we're actually building up an xg
boost model here feeding it in that
training data of iris data and the
parameters that we gave it those are
those parameters and the number of f box
so 10 iterations there and that's just
going to go ahead and make that trained
model based on our training data and as
you can see that happened really really
quick and now to make a prediction
that's also very easy one line of code
we just say model dot predict so we're
taking that trained xg boost model and
feeding in that 20 of data that it
hasn't seen before that we held aside
while training them all to see if it can
successfully predict the species of an
iris just based on the measurements of
its petals and supples
so let's go ahead and kick that off
so now we've stored those predictions in
this uh variable called predictions and
we can print them out see what they look
like
and those are basically all of the
species predictions that it made for
that test data that we set aside this is
the model predicting
what species of iris we have just based
on the measurements of that iris on data
that's never seen before and these zero
ones and twos represent different
species of iris it doesn't really mean
much looking at it though so we need to
actually measure how accurate that is
again that's very easy to do
scikit-learn has a accuracy score
function that can do that for you
automatically we just pass in y test
which is basically the data set of the
correct answers that we know and the
predictions which are the predicted
answers that the xg boost algorithm gave
us let's run that
and amazingly the accuracy is 1.0 that
means that it is 100 correct you don't
see that very often guys and that's very
much a reflection of just how good xg
boost is granted it's a small data set
so it's a little bit easier to get 100
accuracy on a data set that's this small
and easy to work with in the real world
probably won't see that but uh even by
small data set standards that's pretty
impressive so there you go
xgboose in a nutshell and we didn't even
spend any time trying to like optimize
the parameters of it or anything it just
kind of worked out of the box so pretty
cool stuff xgboost is amazing so
you've seen it in action let's spend
some time actually talking more about
the theory now and what's going on here
now i'm going to assume that you're
relatively new to machine learning so
we're gonna take some time and step back
and talk about things like what is a
decision tree what does boosting mean
what are ensemble methods what does it
mean to do train tests or k-fold
cross-validation uh so you know if you
are more experienced in these areas feel
free to just skip ahead through those
sections i won't be offended but we're
also going to talk about xg boost itself
in some detail as well so let's pull up
my slide deck here
all right
so yeah let's talk about xg boost in a
little bit more depth xg boost stands
for extreme gradient boosted trees
and it's what we call an ensemble method
so basically it's taking a whole
ensemble of decision trees and using a
boosting method to boost the attributes
that led to misclassifications of the
previous tree so basically it looks at a
tree that's built to represent our model
of predicting stuff for our data it
tries to find the things that it got
wrong and focuses its energy if you will
on sort of improving the performance on
the stuff that it got wrong and it just
keeps building upon that iteratively
until we get a model that works really
well and it is a really amazing
algorithm i mean you hear a lot about
deep learning these days and you know
neural networks and all that stuff but
um xg xgboost can
definitely give deep learning a run for
its money it routinely wins kaggle
competitions uh even doing better than
deep learning in a lot of cases and as
you can see from that little simple
example we had its performance was
really really good and it's also very
easy to use as you just saw it's very
fast as you just saw so it's usually a
really good algorithm to start with if
you're going to be trying to solve some
sort of general machine learning problem
you know people kind of use deep
learning these days as a jack of all
trades sort of like a hammer to fit
every nail
but xg boosts can often do a lot better
and it's often even easier to use than
deep learning
so let's back up a little bit what do we
mean by a tree in the first place so if
you're familiar with decision trees skip
ahead a few minutes i won't be offended
but decision trees are kind of like a
flow chart right so you can actually
construct a flow chart to guide you
toward a decision as to what sort of a
classification you want to give to a
given problem in machine learning this
is called a decision tree
it's a form of supervised learning which
means that it actually has you train it
with a set of the known correct answers
so it can actually compare its
predictions to the right answers as you
go through the training stage but um
basically you just give it some sample
data and the resulting classifications
that you know are correct and out comes
a tree like this so in this little
simple example that we're looking at
here we're trying to figure out should
we go outside and play today
and uh you know we basically have two
categories that we can come up with
either play or don't play
and we have various features about the
weather is it sunny is it overcast is it
raining is it humid is it windy so the
decision tree tries to figure out what's
the best way to organize these different
decision points as to whether i should
play or not play so
is it gonna be sunny overcast or is it
gonna rain you know based on the
thresholds that i have there i might
have different uh logic as to which way
which branch i take in this tree and
furthermore once i figure out that it's
sunny well i figure well is it too humid
you know right here in florida it sure
is and i can say well if it's less than
70 humid uh go ahead and play otherwise
stay indoors
and
the beauty of it is that a decision tree
algorithm can sort of optimize
automatically what decisions to make
what thresholds to have and what order
to organize these things in and how deep
to go and that's kind of the magic of
the algorithm it does it by doing
something called uh maximizing or rather
minimizing entropy as it goes down so
there is sort of a
way of doing it that makes sense
mathematically i don't want to get too
much into the guts of that right now if
you want to learn more about decision
trees my larger course goes into it in a
little bit more depth
but as an example let's look at a little
example here let's say you want to build
a system to filter out resumes based on
historical hiring data it's kind of a
scary example it kind of uh implies that
uh you could actually decide whether or
not somebody gets a job without a human
being in the loop which is uh
you know obviously cause for concern you
know if you have well i don't want to
get into the ethics of machine learning
but you can get into these situations
where you're baking in the biases of
humans into your training data and you
just end up training your algorithm to
have those same biases which is bad but
i'm not going to go there right now
let's just imagine though that we have a
database of some important attributes of
job candidates and we know ahead of time
which ones were hired and which ones
weren't or maybe even better which ones
actually lasted you know it ended up
being being successful at your company
so you could train a decision tree on
that data and arrive at this system that
would predict whether a candidate gets
hired based on it based on attributes
about that person for example
we could look at how many years of
experience they have are they currently
employed how many previous employers do
they have what's their level of occasion
level of education uh how good was their
school do they do an internship and
based on these features that we call
these various attributes features in the
world of machine learning we could try
to predict the label of whether or not
they were hired so you know we just have
some totally fabricated data here and if
we actually punch that in to a simple
decision tree in scikit-learn we can end
up with something like this and it
actually starts at the top of did you do
an internship it turns out that's
actually a really good predictor as to
whether or not you're going to be
successful in the real world um and in
the little fake data set that i gave it
anyone that had an internship ended up
getting hired so uh we can just stop
right there in that case but if not
we can look at their current employment
status uh if they are not currently
employed then we want to dive a little
bit deeper how many private previous
employers did you have and uh you know
if you're failing that test as well we
can take a look at the quality of the
school that you went to as a last resort
for deciding whether or not to hire this
individual this is a pretty simple
decision tree because it's just linear
you know there's not a bunch of
different branches you can take really
but
the algorithm can figure out
automatically how that actually comes
together how does it work let's go into
a little bit more detail on that so
basically at each step while we're
training the decision tree we find the
attributes that we can use to partition
the data set to minimize the entropy of
the data at the next step and entropy is
basically a measure of disorder you know
it basically gets down to how uncertain
am i about the result at that point in
the tree and there's a fancy term for
that algorithm it's called id3 it's
what's called a greedy algorithm so as
it goes down the tree it just picks the
decision that reduces the entropy the
most at that stage basically it's
looking at
what decision point can i pick that will
give me the most clarity as to whether
or not
the classification i want is correct and
that might not necessarily result in the
most optimal tree but it works and
that's how it generally works now we can
take that and kick it up a notch instead
of just having one decision tree why not
have many decision trees and have them
all kind of like contribute toward the
final results that's what's called a
random forest the problem we're trying
to get around is that decision trees are
very susceptible to overfitting and
we're going to talk about what that
means in a moment
so to fight that we can actually create
many decision trees and have them all
vote on the final classification and we
do that by just randomly resampling the
input data for each tree
and just you know letting them all have
a a go at it and see what's that they
all converge on uh the fancy term for
that is bootstrap aggregating or bagging
and it's just as simple as it sounds we
just sort of like mix up the parameters
going into each tree or the data that it
sees and we let them all vote on the
final result and this prevents
overfitting by not putting all of our
eggs in one model's basket basically
we're letting multiple models be built
on little variations of the problem and
letting them all vote on the best
algorithm so that way you know we kind
of mix things up a little bit more and
we get a more robust result out of the
model
what do we mean by ensemble learning
let's go into a little bit more depth
about that because xg boost is
fundamentally an ensemble approach so
random force like we just talked about
is just one example of ensemble learning
but at a higher level it just means that
we're using multiple models to try and
solve a problem and we let them all vote
on the results in some manner and there
are several different flavors of
ensemble learning as well so the random
force we just looked at uses bagging
bootstrap aggregating the idea there is
that we use many models built by
training on randomly drawn subsets of
the data so in bagging we're just
creating a bunch of different models
using different samples of the data and
letting them all vote on a final result
that's bagging that's not what xgboost
does xgboost does boosting
it's in the name right xg boost so
boosting is an alternate technique that
is arguably even better where each
subsequent model in our iteration in the
in the ensemble boosts the attributes
that address the data that were
misclassified by the previous model so
basically we take a tree we try to
figure out which attributes actually
generated the wrong answers and we give
more weight to those on the next
iteration so we try to like converge on
the problem points of that model and
really focus on getting that better at
each iteration of the of the model so
that's boosting in a nutshell and that's
the basic idea behind xg boost
there are some other techniques in
ensemble learning as well a bucket of
models basically you train several
models using training data and pick the
one that works the best or it's stacking
where you just have multiple models
running at once they can be completely
different models using completely
different algorithms and you just
combine all the results together if you
remember the the netflix prize where
they had a million dollar prize for
improving their movie recommendation
system that was actually the approach
that worked the best for that one
let's get back to xg boost
so xg boost is not just boosting it's
regularized boosting and as we talked
about that prevents overfitting because
we have this ensemble method where we
have many different trees contributing
to the final result and that means that
we avoid sort of again putting our eggs
in one basket and potentially
overfitting to a data set that was given
to one model and we'll talk about uh
overfitting a little bit more in a
moment here another nice thing about xg
boost is that it can handle missing
values automatically so in the real
world you're probably not going to have
perfect data sets
if this were a real data set for iris
flowers there'd probably be a few cases
where you didn't have measurements for
the length or the width of a pedal or a
sepal in some cases xgboos can handle
that for you automatically so that makes
a lot life a lot easier because the life
of a data scientist life of a machine
learning engineer is often spent just
cleaning the data they have so xg boost
removes some of that pain from you
it's also built to do parallel
processing and therefore it's very
efficient so it can actually run these
trees in parallel on the various cores
on your cpu or you know
in theory across different machines but
in generally speaking we're talking
about
different cores on one cpu
it can also do cross validation at each
iteration and we're going to talk about
cross validation next and how that means
and by basically checking how good our
results are at each step that enables
things like early stopping so we can say
okay
you know i've been iterating on this
thing and boosting over this many
different tree models
at this point the result's good enough
i'm just going to stop you know that's
an important optimization to have
especially given how expensive machine
learning hardware is you know both in
terms of money and
energy usage as well
so it can enable early stopping and also
find the optimal number of iterations
basically it knows when to stop right so
that that saves you a lot of wasted
effort
it can also do incremental training but
that means we can start training a model
and as we get new data coming in over
time we can refine that model with that
new data that we're seeing so if we're
getting more and more data data on iris
flowers for example or more and more
data on who was hired and who wasn't we
can feed that in on top of the model
that we have and just keep making that
xg boost model better and better as we
collect more data you don't have to
start from scratch each time so that's
also a really nice feature of it
you can also plug in your own
optimization objectives but the ones
that are built in are usually good but
if you are trying to optimize for
something very specific that's not just
accuracy or something more easily
measured like that it gives you that
flexibility
and it also has a feature called tree
pruning that means that it's just trying
to optimize the the shape of that tree
if you will generally this results in
deeper trees but the trees that are more
optimized so like we talked about before
sometimes the way that
decision tree rainy training works you
end up with uh trees that work well but
aren't necessarily optimized xgboost
addresses that problem through tree
pruning and we actually do
get uh optimized trees that might be a
little bit deeper than you might expect
but they are pretty optimal
let's back up a little bit so we talked
about early stopping and how by
evaluating how good the boosting model
is at each iteration we can figure out
at what point it's good enough so
how do we know how well this model is
doing and if you're familiar with the
concepts of trained tests and uh cross
validation skip ahead a few minutes it's
cool you know i won't be offended but
let's say that we have a set of training
data that includes the value that you're
trying to predict like we do with our
iris data
so we don't have to guess if our
resulting model is good or not you know
we can actually take those known answers
if you will and compare how well our
model does at predicting them
and the trick that we do here is by
splitting it up we have a training data
set and a testing data set the idea is
to only train the model on the training
data and we hold out that test data to
see how well that model does on
predicting uh classifications or values
whatever it is on data that it's never
seen before if you were training your
model on all of your data that's
cheating right like you've basically
given your model the answers ahead of
time so it wouldn't really make sense to
train your model on a data set that
includes your test data you want to
reserve that off to the side and use
that just to evaluate your model
and then you can measure the accuracy of
how well your model does that predicting
the known correct answers in your test
set uh there are various metrics for
doing that like r squared and we just
compare it you know we just look at how
good it is at that point and we use that
to figure out is my model getting better
or worse as i sort of tune the
parameters on it
now in practice uh we end up with this
uh thing called overfitting and that we
can run into so
the danger here in train test is that
you can end up sort of overfitting to
these sort of random variations in the
data that don't really have anything to
do with the intrinsic values of the data
itself so imagine that we're trying to
predict whether a dot should be red or
blue
based on you know some attributes
associated with each dot you know maybe
each dot represents the height and
weight of a person or something i don't
know
but the the
the risk here is that you might end up
with a model that does this like crazy
curvy line to try to like get every
answer right so the accuracy of this
crazy curvy model would be 100 because
it's really going out of its way to make
sure that you know every answer that you
gave it in the training data is gonna be
the right one uh this is called
overfitting right so obviously this
isn't representing anything real this
would not generalize well to other data
because our model is basically
overfitting to the training data that we
gave it a better model would be a
simpler one that just has sort of this
black curve here that's probably more of
a representation of what's going on in
reality as determined in terms of what
attributes result in what classification
so train test kind of addresses that
because by testing this model against
data that's never seen before
an overfitted model would not do well on
that it doesn't generalize like we said
to data that's never seen before so by
reserving that test data we make sure
that we're measuring how well this
this model does on data that's never
seen before and so that will penalize it
for overfitting
however train test is not perfect either
you know if you have a small data set
which we do in the case of the iris data
there is a chance that your training
data set in your test data set might be
weird in the same way right so
take a look at this example here on the
right
our training data set and our test data
set actually have fairly similar
patterns here that it can overfit to so
an overfitted model based on this
training data would actually perform
pretty well on this test data because
just by chance
our test data has some of the same
random fluctuations that our training
data did as well so overfitting can
still happen when you're doing train
tests
so how do we get around that with
something called k-fold cross-validation
so a way to sort of further predict
protect against overfitting is by doing
this multiple times basically so instead
of just having a single training set in
a single test set what we do is this we
take our data and we split it up into k
different randomly assigned segments
and we go through each one of those
segments and in each step we take one of
those segments and reserve that as our
test data take the remaining segments
and use that as our training data and
then we go through each segment and do
it again so basically we're doing train
test k times where we're taking a
different segment of that data that's
been assigned at random as our test data
and the remaining is the training data
so this if you had you know k fold cross
validation with 10 folds you could do
train tests 10 different times and then
basically average the results of how
well the accuracy was on each iteration
to get a more robust measure of just how
good your accuracy is so that's what we
mean by k-fold cross-validation and in
the context of hxg boost that's how it's
evaluating at each step of its training
as to whether or not you're getting a
good result so it's doing
cross-validation and saying okay in the
most robust manner that i know of how
good is my model doing on the data
you've given it and if it's good enough
at that point it can say okay i'm done i
can i can early stop
let's get back to xg boost with all that
uh theory behind us
so like we mentioned if you want to
install it within a python environment
it's super simple you just have to say
pip install xg boost and you're done but
xgboost is not just for python it's
actually a big standalone open source
project of its own and it has a command
line interface of its own it has a c
plus plus interface r julia interfaces
for java virtual machines so it's not
just made for scikit-learn you can
actually use xgboost within pretty much
any application you want to which is
pretty cool
and because it is more general it's not
just for scikit-learn it doesn't have a
scikit-learn specific interface so
because of that that's why we need to
convert things to that d matrix
structure because that's what it's sort
of native api is using to hold the
features and label data
but as we saw already that's very easy
to do from a numpy array within
scikit-learn it's not a big deal it's
just an extra line of code
you pass in all the parameters via a
dictionary like we saw it's very easy to
use you just call train on it then you
call predict on it and you're done super
easy to use
what's the challenge with xgboost though
well
like with any machine learning algorithm
hyper parameter tuning is kind of one of
the hard parts feature engineering the
hardest part hyperparameter tuning close
second i would say and that's true with
xg boost as well sort of the dirty
little secret of machine learning is
that there's not always a whole lot of
expertise that goes into using it a lot
of it's trial and error right so with xg
boost there's a bunch of different
parameters we can adjust what booster do
you want to use there's two of them gb
tree or gb linear what objective
function do you want to use do you want
to use softmax or soft prob
what learning rate do you want to use
that basically adjusts you know what are
the weights used on each step as it goes
through its iteration of doing boosting
that's called ada
what's the maximum depth of the tree
that you want to allow
what's the minimum child weight that's
the way to control under overfitting but
if you get that too high you'll be
underfitting it's not always obvious
what to set these two right because a
lot of times it depends on the nature of
your data
and this is true of any machine learning
algorithm a lot of times you just have
to guess and that's exactly what people
do there's this process called hyper
parameter tuning and often what people
do is they just set up this matrix of
the parameters that they think are going
to have the biggest impact on the
accuracy of their model and they just
try different combinations across wide
ranges of values for each parameter and
as you can imagine that is an extremely
intensive in terms of computing
requirements i mean that means you have
to train your model and test it and
evaluate it many many many many times so
if you have this matrix of many
different parameters and you're trying
different values on each one of those
parameters that explodes really quickly
that's a big part of why training
machine learning model is as expensive
as it is and uses as much energy as it
does because you're trying to converge
on those hyper parameters there are
technologies out there that make it
easier and simpler and faster for
example amazon web services has a hyper
parameter tuning job as part of its
sagemaker service that tries to do this
a little bit more intelligently you know
it tries to figure out as you're going
through the tuning process uh what
parameters are having the biggest effect
and sort of converges on them over time
to you know make that a little bit more
quick and it has the obviously the
the expansive um hardware resources
available to you on aws but again it's
not cheap
so lots of knobs and dials with xgboosa
you can play with and uh unfortunately
getting them right is often just a
matter of trial and error
but yeah xg boost is kind of awesome you
know it's almost all that you need to
know for machine learning in practical
terms i mean for any classification
problem or even regression problems
there's a it can do that as well
regression is where we're trying to
predict a numeric value as opposed to
predicting a classification like what
species of uh a flower do i have so
let's go back to the code again and go
into a little bit more depth this time
and see it in action
all right so we're back at my notebook
here
let's uh go through this one more time
and then we'll call it good so again
we're just using xg boost here and
showing you how easy it is let's restart
our kernel and clear the output start
from scratch
all right so again installing just a
matter of saying pip install xg boost
super easy
and again we're using the iris data set
and let me uh let me pull back that
slide for a moment here
so again we have what we call petals and
sepals you can see here in this close-up
of an iris that there are two different
types of petals on an iris those outer
ones are the petals and those inner ones
are the sepals okay
so our rsa set just has 150 samples of
measurements of the length and width of
the petal and supples
and it has the correct answers of what
species those flowers are so let's go
ahead and hit shift enter to load that
up
and again in the real world you would
not have a perfectly clean beautiful
complete data set like this odds are
you'd have a much bigger data set for
one thing you'd probably have missing
data you'd probably have erroneous data
you'd have outliers that made no sense
so again you know sort of
pruning that data and cleaning it up is
often the biggest part of the job
our larger course goes into that in more
depth and even worse you know you might
have many many many different features
to choose from maybe we had more than
just the measurements of the petals and
sepals and we had to figure out that
those were the most relevant features to
actually use for predicting what species
of flower this is
maybe we also had data on what color it
was or how tall the plant was or you
know where it was grown who knows
oftentimes you just have this sort of
like flood of information that's being
thrown at you in machine learning and
a big part of the job is just figuring
out which of those features are the
important ones for your model that's
called feature engineering and again we
go into that in much more depth in our
course
so we talked about train tests so if you
are new to that hopefully this line will
make more sense to you this time here
we're actually just doing a a straight
up train test we're not doing k-fold
cross-validation we're just going to
take 20 of our data set reserve that for
testing and we're going to train our
model on the remaining 80 so what this
line is doing in more depth train test
split returns to us four different data
sets
numpy arrays more specifically
now in the world of machine learning we
definitely we typically talk about the
feature data as x and the label data is
y
so the label y is the thing we're trying
to predict those are the species of each
flower right whereas x is going to be
the feature data that's going to be the
measurements of the petals and supples
so we're going to take out the feature
data those measurements and split that
into a train test
in a test set
and we're going to take the labels
basically the correct answers and split
that as well into a trained test in a
test set
so we have that into x train x test y
train and y test let's go ahead and run
that block before i forget
now we're going to load up xg boost
itself which we already installed ahead
of time we're going to call it xgb a
shorthand
and we're just going to say xgbd matrix
to can construct that d matrix structure
that xgboost expects
given the x train data
so basically here we're saying we're
creating a d matrix where
the
feature information is from the training
data set and the label information is
from the training set so it's being
passed in those features
of the
width and length of the pedals and
sepals and the correct answers so it can
use that for actually optimizing the
model as it goes
we'll also give it our complete test
data set which will consist of the test
data that we reserved both the feature
data and again the label data so this is
again the measurements and the species
for our test data set
next we define our hyperparameters let's
run that block before i forget
and here we just kind of like took a
best guess as just some parameters from
the documentation here we're actually
capping the depth of the tree to four
the learning rate eta is set to point
three for the objective we're using
softmax
and we do have to tell how many classes
that we have numclass is just how many
different labels do we have so we have
three different species of iris that
we're trying to predict here so that
value is three
that one you don't have to guess about
but the other ones are basically hyper
parameters that should be tuned and like
we said the process of hyper parameter
tuning can be very intensive
we also need to pick how many epochs are
going to run this over that's another
hyper parameter how many iterations do
you want to go uh at the most in in
training this model
so let's go ahead and define those
parameters
and now we can actually train the model
given those parameters and the number of
epochs that we want to use
and that is incredibly quick right
granted is a small data set but even so
uh xgboost is really really fast now
we'll use that trained model to make
predictions notice that we passed in the
training data here for the model and now
we're going to pass in the test data to
evaluate how well that model does in
predicting
things that it's never seen before
again really quick let's go ahead and
print those out these are basically a
list of the species predictions that it
made for each
sample in our test data
and then we can again go ahead and
measure how accurate that prediction was
so we're going to import accuracy score
from sklearn.metrics
call the accuracy score function here
given our test data and the predicted
labels so we're giving it the the known
correct values here basically from our
test data and the predicted species and
we're going to compare those predicted
species to the known correct ones and
measure the accuracy of the model
and that came out again to a perfect 1.0
so that is xg boost in a nutshell hope
you guys enjoyed our sort of little uh
delve into the world of xg boost again
very simple uh easy to use and it works
really really well uh like i said it's
kind of winning a lot of kaggle
competitions lately and it's just a
matter of trying it out getting those
hyper parameters right
and uh pretty much all there is to it if
you wanna learn more about
hyperparameter tuning and feature
engineering and uh more in the world of
machine learning and data science do
check out my course which is uh
presumably linked to in the description
here somewhere and uh yeah again this is
frank kane from sundog education thanks
for hanging out with me for this half
hour and i hope you learned a thing or
two about xgboost and maybe some other
stuff too take care guys